我一直有一个这样的理论，再难的语言，不管是阿拉伯语、拉丁语、波兰语，世界上都有一群人在试用它。
所以只要你找到适合自己的学习方式，和给自己足够的时间，你都能够掌握一年。
学演的这过程就是在拓换自己的世界的边界。
多拥有一门语言，你就多拥有了一种人生。
That's true.。
大家好，我是瑞雪托语。
我是一个生活在上海和意大利之间，喜欢探索文化和自然的多语言者。
同时，我也是一名小红书博主，在小红书上面创作内容已经五年了。
现在我终于开始我自己的播客，和我最重要的栏目同名，叫做成长开箱。
在这里，我会更加延伸地去分享自己在成长，环球旅行中的故事和感悟。
那今天是我们的第二期栏目，我们要聊的就是我这个非常重要的角色。
A polyglot，多语言者。
那我也邀请到了同样是多语言者的我的好朋友，Evan Du。
嗨，大家好，我是Evan，很开心来到瑞雪的播客。
我本身也是一名小红书博主，也是一名时尚从业者，从时装编辑，现在变成了自媒体，从幕后到台前。
也是一名哥哥与爱好者，所以今天特别开心在这里跟大家分享。
今天是一个非常热闹的局，现在是中午晚上，我们就坐在我们的工作室里面，点着香薰辣竹，开着非常温热的灯光来聊这一期话题。
我们两个的生活状态其实非常的像，我们两个其实住的就只有十分钟的步行距离。
我们要两三个月才能见上一次面。
通常是你在一代的时候，我就从乖回来了，然后我要出国的时候，你又在国内。
今天我们先给大家一个警告，就是这一期节目会有非常多的中英夹杂，因为咱们今天就是要把我们所有的语言的人格都给它放出来溜溜。
对，如果就是不喜欢我们中英德什么意义夹杂的话，先说声sorry。
我一直说中英德是我说的比较好的语言，所以我之前在网上有发视频说我自己是polyglot，然后被人质疑说，
什么样才能算是会说，我会说啊听我说我们语言，但他们说那你说的是什么程度才能感出来，这么宣称。
然后我就觉得ok that's a good question，退一步讲我就是tri-lingual，ok period，但是进一步讲卖一步讲我就是polyglot，
因为是要有，我觉得是要有追求的，要aspiration，对。
are you a bilingual or you're a bilingual?。
So，那你给我们讲一讲吧，你会哪几门语言，而且能不能稍微给我们秀一下，不要怕我们听不懂。
咱们的听众都是特别那个什么来自武湖四海、国际视野。
对啊，咱都能会的语言多了去了，你可你千万别怕，你要是说得不好，可有有人在那个评论你可能会那个审讯你。
批版可以啊，我觉得这样子才能够让这个节目活起来嘛。
好，来，秀起来。
我就是就肯定是母语，对，很多人不是都是温州人，我还会温州话，有宇九无。
哎，我的意思是说什么？
你在說什麼 你說了什麼普通話。
然後你以前說 於久。
就是溫州話的意思。
我在說溫州話很多人在上海聽著。
或者國內聽著會以為是日語。
對我感覺我不會覺得它是一個方言。
我如果聽到我可能會以為它是外語。
它是古漢語的一個延伸吧？
所以其實溫州話讀古詩特別好聽。
所以我覺得這是中文最厲害的地方。
因為我們中國實在是太低達悟薄了。
我經常覺得中國的很多的方言。
如果放在歐洲它就是另外一邊語言了。
對 所以我每次跟別人說。
不管是飲食文化語言 甚至氣候上。
你不要把中國跟比如說法國。
這樣一個單一的國家來對比。
它肯定是跟歐洲大陸媲美的。
因為它曾經很多小國家。
然後其實黃把這個地方統一了。
然後經歷各種朝代的更替。
然後才有了今天
所以我們南方人去到北方就會覺得。
這個吃得很不習慣。
甚至比德國和荷蘭他們的差別都要大。
歐洲說白了那種除了什麼安格魯薩克遜。
或者是那種德國人種斯拉夫人種。
荷拉丁人種以外
它們其實吃的還是像的。
大型是麵包加一些醬 對吧？
但國內不是這樣
對 天差地別 難得的差異。
而且我們有五十個民族。
所以還是非常豐富的一個別。
那麼我估計算是英文語。
詳必自嚇
我還是覺得從情話上寫到。
所以我根本選擇空間鎖三四。
你們都聽得懂
你兩個冷革了一個。
我冷革了一個冷革了嗎。
你們聽得懂這啥意思嗎。
不是 你那個哪個人嗎什麼的。
不是 你怎麼這麼這個。
我這麼這個怎麼你了。
好 下一句
那是什麼你的第二句。
第二句肯定是
German
第二句
對
我們說
德國和澳洲的文化。
然後
對 剛才在一個影片。
我寫了一個在網上。
有些人留言說
你講錯了德國
或者是
中國
而不是中國
有些人說
他們在德國和澳洲。
例如在北京
不明白
對 這是
就像我們
對 剛才德語說啥。
我剛才德語說
我其實說德語的時候。
剛開始在小巫上會被人質疑。
說這個德語不過標準。
因為他們聽的是比較不合理。
因為德國也很大
有北邊南邊
然後德國最標準的普通話。
是韓國那邊的標準。
就中部
中部有哪些
韓國
韓國在韓北邊
在北海那
是港口
所以漢堡也是
柏林比較富裕的一個城市。
然後穆尼黑在南部。
是南部比較富裕的城市。
柏林偏北
但是柏林就是剛開始比較窮。
現在已經窮到
現在房租貴了
然後現在變得特別的就是。
他們現在太春麗了。
Living unfriendly。
現在太春麗了
你就是大家都去
就把那個物價轟彈。
德國是歐盟裡面最大的經濟體。
所以它的首都
房價上去也是必然的。
只說它就沒有了以前那種。
藝術家們自由
散漫
然後能夠在各種廠房裡面創作。
然後房租和物價極低的那種時代了。
所以你說的是什麼德語呢？
我說的是奧地利的德語。
也就是跟那個穆尼黑。
比較接近的南部的一個德語。
它會有什麼可音箱的區別。
它會發音比較軟一點。
然後比如說
Chemistry。
就是北邊的德國的德語。
會叫Siemi
然後我們是Chemistry。
OK 第二次可能硬。
但是整體來說比較。
我覺得可能是
British English跟American English的區別。
可能我們跟偏那種American。
就更遠一點
更斷一點
我會寫個
我經常跟你說
罵人的不是
我會這個
Ice Yongxian。
這個是我覺得
世界上最難發的一個語言了。
就是你最難發的一個詞。
就是搞那個
Ice Yongxian。
我覺得發音會有更難的。
我覺得這個好難
OK 那
我們會去我的第二句語言。
其實是英文
所以我開始學習英文。
因為我小時候
很多人都很驚訝
我這樣一個
American accent。
因為我從來沒有
為什麼
我從來沒有在英文說話的國家。
我只去美國
就很短暫地
在高 school。
對
我覺得我只看過
很多藝術的城市
就是這樣
我覺得是一樣的
對
我們沒有
我從來沒有去美國。
我住在 London for a bit。
但是我沒有選擇AXENT。
我可以選擇AXENT。
如果我可以
好可愛
所以我的AXENT。
絕對是很
正確的
根據我的個人性
我自己選擇
And when I try to be push。
I can do some British accent, actually。
And we do that quite often。
Between us。
We do it as a joke。
Yeah
But I feel like I can switch between posh。
and kind of Adele。
Cockney very quickly。
And Adele is much easier to do。
than the posh。
因為我其實
從小到大
一直在學校就是被人。
叫做那個英語很好的女孩。
從小就被那個同學的家長說。
你要多多幫助一下她的英語。
她英語不好
你要多幫助她一下。
然後
我高考的時候英語是144分。
就是我到現在進程會拿出來。
拿出來幾分
滿分150分
這是一件我進程會拿出來。
炫耀的事情
但其實我想的時候。
我的英語是非常差的。
因為我覺得那個時候。
學英語的方式實在是太無聊了。
我覺得那個方式太。
How are you。
硬是這樣
對
所以其實我後面完全是。
因為自己的一些興趣摸索。
開始
自己開放了一個學員的方式。
是因為我後來開始追星。
我喜歡東方神器
他們有很多歌
裡面有英語的單詞。
然後就有很多英語的歌詞。
為了唱他們的歌
我自學了韓語
自學英語
一個小學生
真的嗎
對
那你韓語怎麼樣
韓語我不會講
我只是想學的說
自學了他的拼讀
怎麼拼讀
還有一些他基本的語法。
比如說我們中文是主衛兵。
對吧？
但是他是主兵衛
剛剛上初中
在那個時候
我依然覺得我自己的英語很差。
上初中第一天競選科代表。
我不知道怎麼的
我就去競選了一個英文的科代表。
我就用英語自我介紹。
去想去競選的時候。
比如說 I love English。
English is in my soul。
in my heart。
這不是顯化嗎
這個是那種
不是
這個就是東方神器的那種歌詞。
你會唱的什麼
in my soul in my heart。
我下台了之後
老師被你看到
哇
這孩子英文真好
這英文科代表
就讓他當了
就是這樣一句話
讓我開始相信
我是一個英文好的人。
改變了你的人生軌跡。
真的
我非常感謝這位老師。
這是我的恩師
這是我一輩子的恩師。
所以在那個時候
我才開始覺得我英語好。
我才開始把自己當做一個。
英文好的人去做這件事情。
我就開始看很多很多的。
英文的電影
聽很多很多的英文歌。
我會把這些歌
歌詞全部招下來
背下來
那些英文
電影我在看的時候。
會有一個本
我就是忍不住
如果他講一句
我覺得特別有意思的話。
我一定要把暫停下來。
寫到這本上
我一定是看雙語字幕的。
包括我現在
因為我最近又開始從事法語了。
那我看法語電影的時候。
我一定會看雙語字幕。
而且我一直在看他的劇情。
看到有意思的劇情。
我會反覆看反覆看反覆看。
這也是我一直跟大家說。
我也是這麼自學英語的。
只是我的
Tricks我不看任何字幕。
對
這也是另外一個
當然是可以看字幕。
但我就是什麼字幕都不看。
你就純聽吧聽會
這就有點像你在英語。
或者法語國家生活。
你聽出去外面
你跟人聊天是沒有字幕的。
對
就只能聯繫他們的上下文劇情。
聯繫他們的手勢
然後當然如果你的水平非常差的話。
你可能還是要先學一些基礎的。
一個語法和基礎的 vocabulary。
但是在此之後還是要逼自己。
你越聽不懂的狀態。
然後越沉浸是去看。
其實你的大腦會非常努力的幫你去解讀。
慢慢的就會懂了
不懂的話你把這個。
已經聽到十遍的詞。
你還記不懂什麼意思。
你就去抄下來
你就去查
查那首抄
其實
這是個很好的學習法。
我們剛剛提到了一個非常關鍵的點。
你知道為什麼
我們兩個的方式這麼不一樣嗎。
為什麼
因為人大致
裝為幾種不同的記憶方式。
有圖像型的記憶紡記的人。
有文字型的人
也有那種 audio。
對
聽聲音
你也許就是一個聲音型的人。
而我百分之百是一個圖像型的人。
對
我記所有東西都是通過圖像來記的。
比如說一句話
你給我說一百遍我可能都記不得。
但是你這樣給我看一遍我絕對記得。
包括我從小到大
我背書的方式
就是把這一頁紙
像一張照相一樣
把它照在我的腦子裡。
然後我在說這句話的時候。
我的腦子裡會有這句句話。
出現在我的眼前
對
但記性很好嗎
就是你看
你能夠目光
對我想記的同情
對於言來說
那你很受覺得那個歷史。
藝術史啊？
都很適合
都需要大量的記東西。
而且最好是文字跟圖片。
連接起來
我是理科生
你是理科生
你不是學義大利語的。
但是我高中是理科生。
是嗎
對
所以這個是個非常有意思的方式。
I'm very glad that you said it。
因為很多人
他在記東西的時候。
就是在學園的時候。
他記不住
很有可能
my dear friend。
你沒有找到那個適合你的記憶方式。
首先你找到自己是圖像型記憶。
聲音型記憶還是文字型記憶。
然後你用這個方式來幫助自己。
你的記憶方式會就是突飛猛進。
是的
我覺得很多人在聽到我們這些經驗的時候。
就可以去試
然後找到適合自己的那個才是真的。
因為每個人都學語言是方式不一樣的。
有些人正是靠硬逼。
但我也是跟你一樣是靠興趣。
靠我看我愛看的劇。
然後我也是靠著去模仿。
但你覺得
你知道嗎
我一直有這樣的一個理論。
我覺得學語言
和其他任何的學科都不一樣。
原因就是比如說數學。
世界上可能只有很小一部分的人。
他是精通數學的
或者物理
任何一門學科
世界上可能都有很小一部分的人。
他是精通
但是語言
再難的語言
阿拉伯語
拉丁語
波蘭語
世界上都有一群人在使用他。
但是每個人對語言的造詣是不一樣的。
你說你把一個
比如說中國的文藝文。
吃得比較透的人
和平常可能
對吧？
只是把他當作日常工具來用是不一樣的。
你剛剛那個點是很好。
連說中文也有說的好說的不好。
有的人他只能用非常簡單的語言。
有的人他出口成章。
而且我小時候就發洩了。
有一個點
就是我是在溫州學的語文。
然後我們的語文老師特別好說。
他的發音這樣比較準。
所以他把我們每個人的口音要抓得很嚴格。
他說因為溫州人的問題。
他沒有厚鼻音和前鼻音的區別。
你以前說這個
對以及翹舌音和平舌音的區別。
就有些小孩
他說的就是非常的前厚鼻音不分。
然後有些小朋友就能完全聽老師的發音。
然後做出精準的模仿。
所以我是能明白說。
我覺得首先有語言天賦的人。
他的耳朵一定是靈敏的。
對
而他的舌頭一定是靈敏的。
他肯定能夠聽到這個音。
能夠準確的捕捉到以後。
能很好的再去replicate出來。
再很好的去重複複數出來。
對
所以其實我想是表達的就是。
我們不應該對於學員這些東西感到害怕。
是
對
因為任何一門語言。
他都有一群人在使用他。
不管他們的智力如何。
他們對於語言的掌控能力如何。
或者對語言的興趣如何。
Exactly
所以只要你給自己足夠的時間。
和找到適合你的方式。
你總能夠掌握一門語言。
我們說你的水平有多好。
但是你一定是能夠使用他的。
他說白了就是
為什麼我們沒有
比如說娘胎裡面
為什麼自帶的學員的系統呢？
是因為我必須得跟人交流。
因為人是社交動物。
數學不好點你還能活下去。
但是我今天就跟我弟講的。
他是學計算機專業的。
他是個學霸很厲害。
但是我就想
他今天就文章寫不出來。
但他從來在國外長大。
我們自教他中文還能寫字十字。
我覺得已經不錯了。
但是我今天跟他講說。
我說無論如何
溝通能力是所有的行業裡面。
都要必備的能力
除非你今天就是
我跟你講
就算愛因斯坦
他的情商是極高的。
語言能力是極強的。
溝通能力是極強的。
你再怎麼一個聰明的人。
你不能把你頭腦裡面。
很精密的想法
能夠準確的精準的複數給到。
你想要去複數的
那些人的目標人群裡面。
那你再怎麼聰明
大腦是沒有用的
對
現在AR也是你在。
你在講的AM machine learning。
就是在講那個大模型。
就是一個語言
你在訓練
他不是天天跟他在用那個語言。
在教你嗎
這也是人類和其他動物。
很大的區別之一
比如說他們會通過一些語氣語調。
或者是
他們發音的頻率來表達。
他們想說的東西
但是人類
可以精確到一個字的不同。
是
一個詞的不同
就太厲害了
這個就是中文
一個字不一樣
哇
它表達的情緒和的效率完全不一樣。
或者字讀音完全一樣。
但是可能有50個統音詞。
對
這就是語言文字魅力。
但是人類其實
溝通不僅僅是語言文字本身。
而且還是語氣和那種手勢。
所以其實有時候
有些人對表情
說義大利語
他不一定說得那麼的。
語言說得那麼精妙。
但是他如果音發
對
就會覺得
這個人還挺自信
挺卡卡而談的
我覺得義大利語就是這樣。
它是有自信性的
我覺得不自信的人。
很難把這個語言
就如果我是初學者。
我不自信的話
很難把這個味道給說出來。
那麼我們來到
我的第三語言
所以是 Italian。
謝謝你
你做了100 Italian perfect。
當我講到 Italian。
很棒
其實我學習了 Italian。
在10年以來
我從大學
我也做了一個表演。
在3-4年以來
第一次成為Vlogger。
那所以義大利語
是我的第三語言
也是我曾經吃飯的家伙。
因為我大學的專業。
就是義大利語
我在本科畢業之後。
我又去了米蘭
繼續學了跨文化
交流這個專業
我們叫
溝通和聯合國
國際
包括我自己
在成為博主之前
其實我也做義大利語。
和中文的翻譯
做了很久
如果我當時沒有成為博主的話。
那我大概率
其實可能會做英明。
通傳或者是會
外交官
那個是我非常想去聯合國。
你要就是政界
對
然後說到義大利語。
你覺得我當初是
為什麼學義大利語。
你好像說過
學義大利語
有點記不得了
OK
我告訴你們之前
請你們先 bear in mind。
我當時只有18歲。
而且是個理科生
對
我會因為這些原因做。
是很正常的
就是
首先
我知道我自己英文很好。
所以
那個時候我知道
我一定要學義大利語。
法語
西班牙語
德語學的人好多
沒有聽說過人
學義大利語
那我要學義大利語。
義大利語感覺很不錯。
但是不是學什麼
修雅利語
俄羅斯語
波蘭語
波蘭語跟小時候
這是原因之一
但後來我開始學義大利語。
我才知道
每日學義大利語
是有原因的
因為他們經濟太差了。
對
我經常聽你說起
一些義大利的辦事效率。
每次聽到我就是三滴汗。
對
我記得
我記得我高中畢業。
和我爸爸的一個婆婆吃飯。
就在說學什麼專業嘛？
說出義大利語
這四個字的時候
那個叔叔
那承諾了
他說
為什麼
要學義大利語
對
西班牙語
你去美國也可以做生意。
對
大美國家
法語
說是品
你可以去非洲
我們第二大經濟品。
真的很小中
你是為了小中而小中。
對
但那不是
這不完全
我還打正招
這不是完全的原因。
第二個原因
因為
I'm a lady god。
got sad
and she's Italian。
他都不會說義大利語。
Oh my god。
義大利語
媽的
老實說
他學義大利語
就把他們回家
此刻Cloe從那個椅子上。
彈跳得簡單
如果大家覺得
聲音有點問題的話。
就看看把麥克風彈飛。
但我原來
這不完全的原因
還有第四篇裡面
Sephani German out of。
Sephani
媽的
怎麼會不說義大利語。
沒想到
我可以說義大利語。
但你
你現在因為
那個Lady Gaga。
這個視頻活了以後。
我覺得他們的人
都沒有 reach out to you。
真的很神奇
他們應該
跟你錄一期什麼視頻什麼的。
然後你就可以剛講義大利語。
然後就接上她的膜拜。
對
我
就是給不知道的聽證說一聲。
本人五個月前
在新加坡和Lady Gaga。
剛吃了頓飯
哎
就是什麼回事
其實那時候
在新加坡看了演唱會的時候。
我在外面吃飯的時候。
偶遇了她
然後我就作為一名狂熱的粉絲。
在距離她
5米的距離吧？
盯著她吃了一頓飯。
看著尬尬小姐
吃了什麼
大蝦呀？
特別辣的拌麵呀？
那個什麼啤酒啊？
與此同時
整個過程我在那兒淚流滿面。
後來我把它做成一個視頻。
發到網上
獲得了20多萬的點贊。
在小紅書上面
甚至國外
火遍全網吧？
火遍全網
globaly
她肯定看到了
甚至很多國外的知名們。
媒體像澎湃這些
來找我們要那個視頻的授權。
你給了嗎
給了呀？
咱要火遍全球
我覺得你剛剛應該看到了。
我希望她看到了
globaly I love you if you're listening。
OK
所以我們其實還有第三個原因。
蛤
學義大利的第三個原因。
我不知道呀？
你快說
因為聽說義大利男人失敗。
真的嗎
我覺得義大利女人還不錯。
但是男人就是四三班了。
我覺得爸爸
看你喜不喜歡
我喜歡媽媽男人
是嗎
我愛
和媽媽的關係好多。
那麼難是不就應該。
和自己的媽媽關係好。
我覺得關係好是好。
但是媽寶男就不對。
我覺得義大利的媽寶。
跟中國說的媽寶
不是一回事
他們的媽寶是
視自己的母親為女神。
他們非常非常的
尊重和敬仰女性
他覺得媽媽是世界上最棒的人。
比如說我前男友
他一個一米一九的大小隊。
每次回到他媽媽身邊。
他會一大支拳
鎖在他媽媽的懷裡。
我就覺得很可愛
媽媽呢？
他們有這個詞
就是媽寶男
所以你的第三個原因。
從第三個應該是英語啦。
對對對
對
嗯
隨便說
我也是說
很美式的
有時候我會獲得
網上網絡的評價
知道我有一種
女性的評價
我真的非常強烈的。
真的嗎
我的評價很高
每次我完成了
我聽到我的聲音就很高。
但是我不曉得
我真的不覺得
我真的覺得
哪個女性的評價
我真的很討厭
對我真的很討厭
但是
這就是Cardassian的說話。
他們有
有一個
應該是
紐紐
他們是O.G的影響者。
所以
他們必須要工作
我會看到很多的
國內的網民
大家在網上評論說。
我英文聽力很差
但是我每次看
凱萊山家族我都能聽懂。
我想說
這是因為他們有了。
詞彙量非常的偏僻。
主要是大眾能聽懂嘛？
對不對
其實你
做互聯網也是有時候。
你講太高聲
其實沒人想聽
那所以以往
你為什麼會
講這麼多門語
因為像我的話
我其實是一個
課班出生的一個
語言學生
那你其實
不是學語言的
那你為什麼會講
這麼多門語言
以及你為什麼要學。
這麼多語言
我從小在
我也拿出生長大
不據我的朋友所說。
我認為我是12歲才。
就真正正正
開始非常系統性的。
去學德語
他們就說
你聽上去不像是一個。
12歲才學德語的。
你聽上去就像母語德語。
對
但也有一個白人的朋友說。
你就是還能聽出來。
應該是亞洲人的一個口音。
但是我說你知道嗎。
我的舌頭我的臉
我的肌肉是亞洲的臉和肌肉。
所以如果我聽上去。
是有亞洲口音的話。
很正常
就像很多人會
argue美國的abc。
跟美國的白人
他們的美式音樂
也是不一樣的
就算是同一個neighbourhood。
同一時期長大
所以我覺得ok it's fine。
可能就是我的口腔。
我的頭骨的肌肉
對 你的口頭骨都不一樣。
像黑人
他沒有太字的一個slow。
一個slang
你們的
你們發出聲音的
這不共振的位置都不一樣。
沒比
你們的口腔的形狀也不一樣。
導致你們說出來的口音。
它不會一模一樣
我現在年紀大了以後。
反正覺得口音
是特別有魅力的一個東西。
我也覺得
如果我們每個人
都是說標準的
我也覺得
普通話
沒有一點你的口音。
沒有南北方的差別。
沒有方言的話
就甚至變得超級無聊。
很多文化會直接原地消失。
我也覺得
比如說
一個人他一進來
他一張口
你就能聽出來
他是哪兒的
甚至他帶有一些
他們國家的
一些風情
在他講的這個英文裡面。
會非常非常的有魅力。
而且我覺得你為什麼。
要去掩蓋你的出身。
你來自於哪裡
你走過這些路
你帶過的地方
為什麼要去掩蓋呢？
對
所以我現在就不會去。
很刻意的去
一定要發一個完美的。
美式音譽的強調了。
我會讓自己在講英文的時候。
更放鬆一些
那有一些詞
或者是在說一些東西的時候。
我帶一些口音
他甚至有可能
不是中文口音
有可能有點一大羽口音。
或者是什麼的口音。
難免的
因為你說多了
我就覺得
介紹也會發生變化。
I love it。
就像中國的外交官。
他們的口音是一種。
有點中式的國際音譽。
非常好聽
因為它是一種
代表著深思熟慮的。
有點政治立場的
有態度的這麼一個。
它是一個非常精妙的設計。
所以我覺得說語言。
其實你怎麼說都無所謂。
但是你要明白
就像我剛才說的溝通。
也是你要明白
你在什麼場合
什麼形式
對什麼的目標
進行什麼的溝通
你要明白這些原理。
你明白今天要溝通的目的。
以後你怎麼溝通
就是你可以有一點點。
自己的創意發揮
只要達到這個目的的話。
就能達到這個目的前提下。
有一點點創意沒有關係。
而且我聽說過一個有關口音。
特別酷的一個說法。
他就說如果我有口音說明。
我現在在講的是我的第二文明。
說明我不只會說一種語言。
對
所以德語就會了
英語的話跟你一樣。
淳淳是很喜歡看電視。
12歲就經常坐在電視前看MTV。
那時候德語和英語是同時學的。
就有點搞混
但是我信號
我那時候的英語老師。
真的嚴格
然後把那個口音抓得很好。
因為我能聽出來
德語的口音的英語。
所以我會為了避免說成那樣子。
就我會看很多的美式的電視。
英俱美俱這樣子
我們在10禮拜的時候就沒有了。
10禮拜的時候就沒有了。
嗯
我講了一點點英俱美俱。
啊 對
我也是一小段時間。
我學習了一個學校。
我也是
一個學校
嗯
兩個
一個學校
但是
是一個很困難的學校。
但是更容易
是你講了
意大利人
或
西班牙
或蘭南
對 因為他們的語法是非常相近的。
那我其實法語是
大學的時候在意大利學的。
avec les copains d'italien。
avec les professeurs d'italien。
donc j'ai l'accent d'italien。
所以
我
我跟很多法國人一說法。
他們說
你的法語怎麼是一部意大利。
口音
對啊？
這代表你走過的路嘛？
就一追溯就完全明白了。
因為你的法語是意大利人教的。
對
就像有些老外
師教的
有些老外去那個
彎彎去學那個
國語
然後他們說
就是彎彎的這個口音。
你好笑
對
所以我覺得口音是一件超級富的事。
它代表著你的來歷。
是的
它代表人生走過那些路和經歷過的故事。
對
但是我覺得
當你學了意大利
或者
而任何一門羅曼語族的語言的時候。
你再去學法語
我覺得它非常的簡單。
因為它的大致的語法是類似的。
而且詞語是很類似。
這讀音不一樣
不怕的讀音給換一換就行。
是
然後再加上一些法語。
特殊的
口音用處
只為了它的一個
形式的美
美味啊？
對
或者是它那些完全不發音的那些結尾的。
ST
D這些東西
所以我覺得這個是很有意思的一個點。
你可以通過一個國家的語言。
看出來它的文化
對
而且你們看出來以前語言。
它們還是同一種的時候。
它們的相似之處
就像不是pasta。
就是義大利語
義大利麵的意思
Farid pisa pat。
然後它那個R上面有個這樣子的一個。
一個像橋一樣的
對像倒過來那個中文的Pin T3上。
對
那個就是pat
或者otel
其實有這樣子的一個標的意思。
就是其實以前除了在T前面還有個S。
所以是pasta hostel。
對但它把這個S去了。
然後加了一個
在這個原因上加了一個小屋子的屋頂。
對我就lotel pat。
所以追溯起來
它們還是同一個
對它們都是拉丁語的。
同一個宿園
希臘語
法語而也來的
那它們可能就是不停的。
再給自己加了一些個型。
就比如說法語
它加一個小尾巴
再一個小帽子
它們就變成了各自的發言。
而且它會特別遵從前後的那個平衡。
你說不的時候
你不能只說不
你不能只說ner。
ner的後面還有再加一個巴。
就是它的各種形式上的東西。
然後我有感覺義大利語。
就特別像一個直雙的大姐。
怎麼寫就怎麼唸
沒有任何一些多餘的玩意。
就跟它們的性格也很像。
所以我覺得其實我們在講不同語言的時候。
也有不同的人格
我們在講的是不同的文化。
不同的習俗
你有些什麼人格
人格
你覺得你在講了一個不同語言的時候。
人格有什麼區域
我只聽說比如說我跟你這樣說中文。
然後我突然說德語的。
它你們發現我的語調是變調的。
但我不清楚
就說德語的聲音會低。
然後英語聲音會高。
中文其聲音還算高。
中文算高的
因為其實每一個語言。
它的發音的位置就是不一樣的。
那像英語的話
它其實很多的發音位置是在後腦上。
你發不發現在
它的位置是很高的。
然後你說話的姿態之靈就是會不一樣。
白索我說英式音
我聲音會更高
Oh yeah
Thank you。
When I was in boarding school in Switzerland。
we had a British English teacher。
and she was really lovely。
Really darling。
Yeah I mean she was really amazing。
she taught us so much。
Oh my god really。
I mean she taught us。
she was not very dissentive。
說德語的時候聲音會更低。
而且性格也很不一樣。
成文一點說德語的話。
我覺得我說中文的時候特別知識大理。
然後說重新化的時候。
就十幾個
超破糧
一個坐在街邊敲著二郎腿。
坐在板凳上
用板凳接著吃香片。
在上面一個人
而且我說重新化的時候。
沒有辦法比媽髒話。
我太愛用重新化媽髒話了。
而且我覺得我說重新化。
比我說任何一門其他的話。
都要搞笑100倍。
而且你又大優勢樣子裡面講。
小話很罵人
對
就比如說
我跟Teprus包西龍。
有一塊的是鄧超龍。
就是說我覺得這個人很傻。
傻的他內褲都是鄧超龍做的。
我也不知道是什麼。
就是為了押韻
然後說義大利語就是一個。
性感豪放的女孩
是嗎
對
我會覺得自己有點。
我其實最早看過你的視頻。
是你唱
Mohito好像什麼。
是用義大利語唱的那首。
翻唱那首歌
我這句話安排好
很做心很熱情
你覺得學語言給你帶來什麼便利嗎。
比如說在約會上
有沒有
因為特別會說外語。
能夠撩到更多的帥哥。
那倒沒有
我覺得我對那種
異國帥哥首先沒那麼感興趣。
對
我比較喜歡就是
這個男的為了我去學一門語言。
不是我為了他學
憑什麼呀？
就我就是很多異國情侶。
如果說雙方都不說彼此的母語的話。
他們就會用第三方語言說話。
就用英語
吵架也是沾沾比較公平。
我談過一個男朋友。
他是奧地利人
然後我已經是
算是就是這個文化了解得非常深刻了。
很透徹了
然後去他家也是
對吧？
習俗什麼都懂
甚至那種他們村裡的那些方言。
和搞笑的一些slang。
我也學了
但是我就覺得
為什麼我要融入到你的這個文化裡面。
然後你們可能一句普通話都不會說。
就我覺得我懂太多了。
你懂我意思嗎
我變成了一個
我可以適應所有的辨識人。
那你誰來適應我呢？
你怎麼能明白一個說。
三國四國五國語言的女孩的內心事件呢？
如果你只說一門語言的話。
你在你那個村長長到這個奧地利男孩。
which is totally fine。
just take someone from your village。
ok no maybe not。
you can take whoever you want。
對
但是我不能理解的是。
語言完全無法溝通的異國情侶。
我也覺得也很奇怪。
but obviously it's just me。
我是一個對語言和對溝通文字語言上的溝通的。
要求非常高的一個人。
我特別討厭辭不答應的人。
我也特別討厭就是辭不答應的我自己。
所以
對
如果我想去發言的話。
當然是最快的方式肯定是他跟法國。
對象
那就可以真的會逼自己。
因為我想要去能跟他表達一些我的想法。
但是
我個人覺得還好啦。
就是我不會說刻意想要去。
聊什麼異國男人就還好。
對
那我們兩個很不一樣。
因為最近我又開始重學法語了。
就是因為我認識那個法文的男孩。
小外丹
我覺得他在說法語的時候。
特別的有魅力
他講自己母語的時候。
這是最真實的他
以及他的聲音
各方面他的表達都是他最自然的方式。
一方面也是因為他英語不那麼好。
所以他說英語的時候。
起碼不那麼的聰明。
我就特別喜歡看男人酒破的樣子。
Girl
You're different。
趕緊跟我們說說
然後你們今天發言學得怎麼樣了。
重拾
Oh my god。
我學法語的動力好強。
我都突然發現我的法語凸飛夢盡。
果然是需要靠愛情的力量。
又是雙語座
這個是前段時間
我和這男孩認識的時候。
和他一起的另外一個法國人。
跟我說的
他呢？
是個法國人
他的義大語叫得特別好。
就是因為他曾經有一個義大利的女朋友。
他就說
他們告訴他一句話。
叫做
Invarrario na lingua。
Cona lingua。
那 lingua有點意思。
一個是語言
一個就是舌頭
用你的舌頭學有沒有語言。
是學
我學最好的方式
對
咱就不用說啥意思了。
不用說
當時呢？
和這男孩在一起的時候。
語言特別好玩的事。
他教了我幾個詞
都特別的random。
我們走來路上
他就說
柳樹
用法語是
so le
就是柳樹的
柳樹的統稱
這種一坨
這種類型的樹的統稱。
so le
然後貴貴的就說
你要朝用法語是
ni on ni。
而且他會很認真地跟我說很多遍。
我當時還嘲笑他我說。
but why do you have to know these words anyways。
為什麼要叫我這麼。
就在這一張天羅帝王。
就說法語浪漫的那些聲調。
把你撕繞進去
然後
他說你不知道
馬上一個星期過後。
你就要開始報法語班了。
神奇的事來了
他走了之後
我發現這幾個詞
就深深地烙印了
在我的腦子裡
他教我的所有詞
還包著什麼
lambé au bou la fa。
最後的是最好的
就他教我的所有動作。
我都記得
是因為我能夠記得。
他告訴我這個詞的那個場景。
和他說這個詞的那個嘴巴的形狀。
和他的那個聲音
所以我覺得
如果你想要學一個語言。
你要給自己一個非常強的動力。
你要給自己一個語言。
你為什麼要學這個。
你一二十期的原因就是。
你要學回媽媽的語言。
這樣就可以跟他交流。
一個更好的把你的訴求表達給他。
你現在就是你要把這個語言學得更好。
你就可以跟他說一些浪漫的情話。
然後你知道嗎
我突然覺得我的
認讀流氓被打通了。
我突然發現那些我。
三四年前學的法語。
崩了一下子
又回到了我腦子裡。
所有的那些詞
我全都記得了
因為在我離開學校後的兩年裡面。
我一直沒有機會使用法語。
那我一直也對法語。
就沒有那麼的有信心。
所以就慢慢的見望。
我覺得OK
我好像也忘了差不多了。
但和他在一起那兩天。
哇
我的法語簡直是好極了。
這就是愛情的魔力吧？
能讓死去的記憶突然浮現。
對 對於一個雙字不來說是的。
還有剛剛你說的另外一句。
我覺得挺有意思的。
就是你說一個
只說一門語言的人。
他可能沒有辦法理解一個。
說多門語言的人
因為我覺得我在說。
不同語言的時候
我們表達的方式不一樣。
我們展現的角色和性都不一樣。
甚至要討論的主題都不一樣。
所以如果你不能講這門語言。
你永遠都觸及不到這一部分的我。
對 每個語言他都有些。
他自己獨有的一些專屬的詞。
會是無法被翻譯的。
這是為什麼我們在音樂裡面。
有些叫Zyde Guys。
或者是Sharpnfoil的這樣子的詞語。
這個詞就只在這個語言和語境下面通用的。
這是為什麼學習小語言。
在等於學習另一個民族的思維。
你看那個電影《降臨Arrival》
說很像一部科幻片。
我不具同的情況下跟你講。
這大體是
這聖女主是一名語言學家。
然後他有一天被召喚去一個非常神秘的mission。
他要去跟外星人對話。
跟外星人對話的過程當中。
他就發現他吸得了他們的思維方式。
後面就破解了那個謎題。
非常非常神秘
他是那個劉慈欣的三體的那個英文的一喆劉雨昆。
對他的作品
然後對這很厲害
他那個你看他又能寫英文的科幻小說。
然後又能把中文的小說翻譯成英文。
我覺得這是挺厲害的。
我覺得能翻譯的人通常兩美女都要學的非常精彩型。
對而且翻譯他又是另外一個東西了。
你光會說兩個原聲是說的很好。
你也不見得是一個好的翻譯。
是
因為我們當時就是學的翻譯的這個專業。
我們有學翻譯的課程。
那翻譯他不是說我把這個詞翻譯成中文裡的那個詞。
而是說我看了英文的這一句話。
我理解了他的意思。
我在用中國人看得懂的方式。
和符合中國人思維的方式。
把這句話給轉馬出來。
對
他其實是個轉馬
對你要的是讓當地的人能理解到。
意思而不是一比一的就是照著翻。
這就是為什麼很多人看Google translate。
看機器翻的東西看不懂。
那是為什麼國外長大的小孩。
有時候他那個語言的順序會有點不一樣。
我沒有一把剪刀
就是好像是我說問不了一次。
對我說了
對
因為我發現像我們這樣對語言特別敏感的人。
會因為可能對方都說的一個詞。
或者是一個語調
就探測出一些他生活的諸思蠻機。
就發現他現在用的不是中文的語言邏輯。
而是可能英語的語言邏輯。
對
好像有一次你說什麼。
我有什麼一個就被我識破了。
我說以豐
你剛剛說的是英式中文。
對
英式內和的中文
反正我想說那個電影就是非常推薦大家去看。
學演的這個過程就是在透過自己的世界的邊界。
擴充自己的腦中
我兩句話一個電腦一樣。
你為什麼只有一個OS系統。
你可以有多個不同的。
可以隨時切換
那你覺得會多沒遠。
這件事情會在生活上面給你更多的信心嗎。
自信心
在性還好
會不會是安全感
安全感還好
我是一個比較喜歡學會當地的語言。
再去一個地方
也不是說我當然還會去。
有陌生的語境的地方旅行。
但是我為什麼在去完上海。
那時候在上海做完時裝編輯。
又回到了柏林
去那邊定居
就是我就覺得得以我肯定能性。
對
如果說我今天要去一個新的地方的話。
以方面的壓力是來自於學語言。
因為我不可能在一個地方。
待個什麼三年五年不去學。
這個語言是不可能的。
你今天就要把我丟到什麼匈牙利。
雖然我最匈牙利語一點。
興趣都沒有
也是非常難的一門語言。
但是我會把它學起來。
我也是
因為我覺得
我如果不去學的話。
我就不懂這個地方到底是什麼樣子的。
我就是活得像一個文盲。
或者是一個非常完全的一個。
局外人我不想這樣。
我也是
我可以不融入文化。
我可以不除以他們的意願。
但是我得懂
我也是
我想聽明白他們在說什麼。
對
我特別受不了我在一個陌生的國家。
我走在路上看不懂他的路牌是什麼。
哪是出口哪是左哪是要上下左右。
就會讓我非常的沒有安全感。
是
所以我一般去一個地方。
我特別注意他的
每一個地方的標識。
過幾天了之後
我往往就會能夠知道。
這個大概是講的是什麼意思。
而且我也是沒有辦法忍受。
我在一個地方
我聽不懂我身邊的人在講什麼。
我沒有辦法加入他們的談話。
這會讓我如坐掙扎。
是
我也受不了我用那個語言。
就是我無法講笑話。
如果比較大聲
又不敢的時候會讓我很受挫。
對
所以比如說我去新疆玩的時候。
他們都說韓語
那我一定會跟著學幾句韓語。
我至少到後面我能夠通過抓一些關鍵詞。
能夠知道他們在說啥。
就是什麼
走吧？
好啊？
謝謝這些東西我一定要知道。
否則我就會特別的難受。
而且沒有那麼難了。
其實就像音樂學員一樣。
他是不斷的重複
但你要有意識的把這些重複。
變成對你來說有含義的信息。
不記得很清楚
我12歲剛回到
我也拿了東西在課堂上。
可能上學第一天吧？
我就聽了老師在課堂上講。
各種德語寫黑板字什麼的。
然後你聽不懂的時候。
你就覺得
這句歌來這句歌來。
咕嚕咕嚕咕嚕咕嚕咕嚕咕嚕咕嚕。
就聽上去是這樣子的。
而且大腦因為聽不懂。
他會把他自動分類為沒有用的信息。
就像我說你記不懂。
就Gibberish。
對
才會分類成一些噪音。
所以你在智商有意識去聽。
然後要跟大腦說
這是有用的信息
只是我們現在還沒有辦法去解。
但是我們得集中注意力。
我們得去在這個Gibberish裡面。
找到一些規律
對
所以其實我覺得
在生活當中
能夠注意到很多這些細節。
以及你對於想知道。
這些含義的衝動
它其實都歸難於語言天賦的一種。
我覺得是
還有什麼特徵是你發現。
你身邊有語言天賦的人。
對
我覺得
一定程度上的喜歡說話。
他們會喜歡聽自己的聲音。
我們在家裡的話
你可以安靜的看本書。
但是你會選擇朗讀。
然後你會喜歡給人發語音。
好兇詞
你怎麼知道我
然後喜歡莫名其妙隨地大小唱。
就是姐的聲音還真不賴。
你喜歡自己的聲音。
在空氣裡面產生振動的感覺。
這沒有什麼折磡
就很正常
我的師傅
就是我的一個很好的道士朋友。
他會跟我講
他說你有時候經文也好。
你要鼓勵自己的話也好。
你寫下來很好
但是你就要把它唸出來。
朗讀出來了以後
你會在空氣裡面產生共振。
你說真的
我們聽說什麼
能量頻率
政治高能量低能量。
就是這個能量共振的一個頻率。
你當你能量共振以後。
比你單單看是不一樣的。
我們今天說話
就像我特別喜歡說話的。
還有一個點針跟語言無關。
就是我大腦裡面
很多的亂七八糟的思緒解不開。
也理不清的時候
我一旦把它變成語言。
它就像變成麻花變眼。
就變成了一個一條條通順的菌子。
它是在幫助我去釐清思緒。
但如果說你是那種不喜歡說話的人。
你可能journaling。
寫下來
我不知道你可能做運動。
我不知道什麼能幫助你釐清思緒。
但是我只要跟別人聊天。
我通常能夠把自己腦子裡的。
亂七八糟的想法弄明白。
而且還能跟別人的對話當中。
拼砲這樣子一來一回的過程當中。
能誤出很多東西和學到東西。
我也是
有時候我有很多想法。
可能它是半成型的。
我會再跟人家說的時候。
我突然說出一句
讓我自己都很驚訝的話。
原來是這樣見解
對
我會說
我看起來很聰明
還有另外一個我發現的。
共性就是那些發音比較好的人。
往往
他的音樂性都比較高。
是
因為其實你大腦裡面。
去管控聲音的音樂的。
你的語言的語音的。
它是同一個部分
你有沒有發現那些歌手。
不管他們的音與水平如何。
但是他們的發音往往都非常的漂亮。
是的
而且我發現
我還有點發現
就你剛剛說的
比如說多才多藝的人。
不管是stand up comedian那種。
清津喜劇的
或者是你是
stand up comedian。
sorry 是脫口秀演員。
或者你是歌手
或者你是話劇演員。
或者是那種
whatever。
只要是
我覺得很多有才藝的人。
他們語言的能力通常也很好。
因為他們好像模仿。
對 模仿也是
模仿也是
就是像你說的音調也是。
我能聽到這個音調。
雖然我其實我沒有學過任何聲樂。
我連讀音譜也不會。
我就是在學校學了。
但是你唱歌
那句歌我就亂唱
我就亂唱
但是我會模仿那個調。
I can't hit the note。
對
因為我能聽到那個調。
我能夠復述出來
對 這個完全是跟我們。
純粹是模仿
大家是有關係的
因為對於有的人來說。
就是他們的天賦
在別的地方的人來說。
他聽不出來這些區別。
他聽不出來這個音調的區別的。
所以這就是為什麼。
我一直覺得
大家不需要在語言這件事情上面。
對自己特別的嚴格。
說我為什麼不能夠發音。
發到特別標準
自稱的唱員
你有可能你的天賦在其他地方。
這個真的是和我們。
你一個人天生的很多東西。
是有關係的
不完全是說
你又多努力這件事。
確實 確實就完統一。
我覺得我們今天兩個。
想跟大家分享
也就是我們真的
很少有一個機會
花好幾個小時
完完全全治療這個語言。
而且我們倆是有多共鳴。
如果說
你的天賦在其他地方。
完全沒有關係
原則說
你會語言的一個好處就在於說。
你張嘴大就能聽見。
所以這個tialen是比較外顯的。
你有些tialen可能是。
你有附近你還得脫了衣服。
大家能看見
或者是 對吧？
你畫畫你還得坐下來。
你畫個半個小段
才能看見你的天賦。
對
所以它是一個說證。
它不太公平
所以你是什麼時候。
發現自己有原天賦的。
我從小就知道
你怎麼知道的
有沒有什麼事
就說這小孩子原能力很強。
對
我是怎麼發現的
是我到現在就記深刻。
我剛剛說要重慶化。
那重慶化也是有等級制度的。
那當然對高等級制度。
就是適中心的重慶化。
再往下分
我們含曲線口音
就是不是主程區的人。
那我就不是主程區。
國內很多地方都是這樣。
對 我就不是主程區。
大家的
我主程的地方
它的名字很漂亮
叫喬河
是一個小村落
村落
就是一個小寨
到底是什麼
你別的
咱們平常叫人要噴你了。
純真結合
而且明明是
純真結合部
我們的口音就非常的突出。
比如說重慶化
這優雅的說
慈凡
促氣慈凡
但是用我們那兒的方案。
就是她的
跟你們優美的名字。
姐姐
那個哥哥不入
對 促氣慈凡
其實小時候有一次。
我去主程修保兒
我就跟一群小伙伴在一起。
我就跟我的伙伴說。
促氣慈凡嗎
我們要回家猜法呢？
結果就沒幾個
主程修的小孩子
狠狠的嘲笑了
我現在都記得
他們站在那個樓梯上。
嘲笑你
嘲笑我的樣子
真的
果然地域其實很嚴重。
文中也是這樣
弄成修的嘲笑歐海的。
然後呢？
然後我就決定
我回去
要做一個主程修的孩子。
我痛定思痛
我要看是學習主程修的口音。
打不過就加入他們。
您猜怎麼著
幾個月之後
誰也聽不出來
咱是從那個橋合出來的人了。
一開口
那純正的主程修的口音。
咱要發現主程修口音。
得簡單
就改那麼幾個詞就行了。
是的
然後我就發現我自己。
真有一點點
你每次都要受到一些情緒上的刺激。
每次都是情緒使人。
對
就是一個被情緒操控的女人。
是
而且我想說
我能發現她們發錯音。
因為她們位置沒有發對。
我跟她說
比如說
老外不會發謝謝
中文的那種X
對大家特別難想
謝謝
秀
我就說
你把兩個牙齒咬在一起。
再讓空氣從兩個牙齒之間。
輕輕的
她們說
sir
我說
first of all。
舌頭不要給我捲起來。
中文大部分是
沒有舌頭捲舌的
除非這是肉
對吧？
我說
你舌頭放不平
謝謝
其實是
兩個牙齒咬在一起以後。
輕輕的分開以後
讓空氣穿過
然後她們一試就會了。
我發現其實
什麼人都能交換
那你必須得加她嘴巴。
舌頭牙齒
然後空氣的運輸的方式。
所以這個是很多人。
她們在學習語言的時候。
發音上的一個困難。
就是你不可以
用自己的母語的發音的方式。
去發一個外語
因為
有很多外語的音
在你的母語中不存在。
而你母語當中的音。
在外語也不存在
這就是為什麼比如說。
X
有人說X
X就是不存在的
是的
我覺得
為什麼很多時候
我自己有時候也覺得很好笑。
就是那種德國的人說英語。
或者是有時候我們說Chinglish。
我們剛才說了嘛？
就可能是百合幾放的一個事情。
就是越多越不同的越好。
但是我會就是
我們一聽就聽出來。
為什麼這個發音是錯的。
就因為她還是說自己非常。
偷懶的方式在發音外語。
哦 對
我就是偷懶了
但是沒關係
你們知道嗎
說話就說
我們不 judge。
對 我們只是在給你們一些。
比較實用的方法
只是在分享自己的觀察。
對 是我們多年總結下來的一些方法了。
對
我前天在小紅書上面看到一句話。
我覺得說的特別有意思。
他說多擁有一門語言。
你就多擁有了一種人生。
That's true。
你覺得
這些語言有給你一個什麼樣的人生。
我覺得她的確讓我變得。
更具有冒險的心理。
以及我整個人
我會覺得這個世界。
讓我行
嗯
世界是我的努力
我也是這麼覺得
我的溝通能力讓我在哪裡都能活得很好吧？
是嗎
是我怎麼樣
去用自己的方式影響世界。
和與世界產生鏈接的方式嗎。
既然現在
這麼多的發達的軟體。
可以幫助你去發音。
那你幹嘛還要學
我覺得那是不一樣的。
你們人與人之間直接的交流。
我們語言的交流
這是不一樣的
我有個問題
這是個哲學的問題。
如果Neuralink。
現在的那個腦神經。
和這個機器聯動的這些。
科學越來越發達了。
有一天你就像
這個用U盤插入你的大腦裡。
就能夠自動的加載。
一門新的語言
你跟母語就是完全沒有區別的。
你的理解也是完全沒有區別的。
你願意直接下載嗎。
Oh my God, good question。
呃
我就我現在的想法。
我們就是假設的這麼說。
呃
立馬學會發語
我不願意
不要
我喜歡學習的這個過程。
我喜歡從不知道到知道。
一點點的去理解他。
重複他
到可以掌握他
這是一個非常有成就感的過程。
你果然是拼人你喜歡過程。
喜歡體驗
我喜歡從無到有的這個過程。
我覺得
除非是你直接給我打一千萬。
那可以
啊？
給你知識還要給你打錢。
不是
我是說
錢是可以直接給我。
但是知識我希望是我自己慢慢的習得的。
我覺得它是
那有時候
賺錢的過程不能好好享受啊？
一磚一瓦
把自己的工作室
把自己的事業做出來的感覺也很美妙。
也是一個很棒的旅程。
我也可以有錢的
也一起做啊？
有錢了以後再一磚一瓦的繼續不要。
我覺得知識它是有溫度的。
你為什麼記得這個東西。
因為它對你來說重要。
你為什麼想要知道這個東西。
因為你對它好奇
你擁有什麼知識就代表你在乎是你時期。
嗯
還是很情感倒想
那你呢你願意嗎
語言的話我願意啊？
對啊就直接
you know what give it to me。
哈哈哈哈
給我吧來
練肩起來
哈哈
那那你現代
你再學一門一半你學一半吧？
嗯
我就是屬於那種特別刻板出身的思維。
比如說我去土耳其旅遊的時候。
我就會去YouTube上面。
搜一個講這個國家。
它這個語言的整個體系。
我想知道它是屬於哪個語言體系的。
它的語法有哪些特色。
我是特別迷戀語言學和語法這些東西的。
我覺得它有一種數學性的魅力。
因為它只是一個系統嘛？
對它是一個人造的系統。
對我覺得這個東西都要說特別有魅力。
它傳遞了他們的價值觀。
那你接下來想學一門新語言的話能想學是嗎。
哦
我覺得阿拉伯語還挺感興趣的。
我不是真的想說到流利。
我覺得倒也是不一定有這麼時間。
但是我會很好奇
畢竟穆斯林他們是全世界這麼大的一個人口。
我就我對他們的了解是很少很少的。
我接下來想學的就是土耳其語。
那所以我們就總結一下吧？
學一門語言不管你學它好壞。
你都可以了解這個文化它的思維。
只是一個特別好玩的一件事。
不管你這門語言說的怎麼樣。
但是你掌握一門語言。
你在國文之外形作的時候。
你會更加的有安全感。
它給你一種global living的底氣。
是的
然後我覺得有時候不要給自己它的壓力吧？
我們今天談就是我們這麼幾十年來。
學外語的一些心得和觀察。
我覺得大部分人他不敢說。
還是因為他這種羞恥感覺就別人在嘲笑你。
其實沒有
我覺得勇敢做自己的表達人永遠值得尊重。
就算我們出球
然後對把他天天說錯。
的確被人笑過情況下。
還是繼續說才能到今天這樣的底部。
就不要想那種急於求成吧？
過程可能就是旅途本身。
所以我覺得學外語言就像是去世界不同的地方旅行一樣。
是大腦的一場旅行。
那謝謝大家今天的說聽。
謝謝
咱們下次見嘍
我們下次見啦
Bye bye
我為什麼說下次見。
我再說
謝謝Cloy的邀請。
我們下次見
Bye bye
你還會來哦